[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
like a defrosted caveman Brendan Fraser
arrived out of nowhere when he starred
as a titular Encino Man in 1992. George
of the Jungle which is one of my
favorite movies of all time was more in
that 90s style while 1998's Gods and
Monsters showed off Frasier's range now
it wasn't until the release of the 1999
Blockbuster The Mummy that turned
Frasier into an international star but
flops began to mount and though Frazier
was in Best Picture Winner crash so was
half of Hollywood even the mummy
unraveled the box office returns four
returns were good but the Rachel
weissless Tomb of the Dragon Emperor
Bond killing the franchise in 2008.
foreign
[Applause]
by 2010 we were witnessing Frazier
getting blasted by skunks in Furry
Vengeance and yelling up Miley Cyrus as
an expletive after Timmy's shelter
Fraser seemed to be no longer cast in
movies at the end of the decade
Frazier's voice was being heard again
Frazier has emerged as a popular figure
in the celebrity world one whose fans
are drawn to because of his survival
through mistreatment and struggle
Frazier was once mocked and laughed at
but is now generating easy and eager
Goodwill after culture re-examination of
victimhood and predatory Showbiz
Behavior directors seemed glad that
Frasier's around again Steven Soderbergh
put him on screen in no sudden move
Frazier's first certified fresh movie in
17 years and the comeback continues with
his casting and Darren aronofsky's the
whale and Martin scorsese's killers of
the flower Moon so let's take a look at
this blast from the past and a few new
titles too as we count down the best
Brendan Fraser movies
foreign
[Music]
number 10 George of the Jungle
George has raised himself since he was a
baby and a plane crash stranded him in
an African jungle now as an adult George
has his first human contact in years
when he rescues Explorer Ursula Stanhope
from a lion George and Ursula connect
and she leaves her fiance Lyle and takes
George back to San Francisco but when
George turns that his gorilla buddy has
been captured he and Ursula return on a
rescue mission starring Brendan Fraser
Leslie Mann Thomas Hayden Church and
directed by Sam Weissman critics say
George of the Jungle is faithful to its
source material which unfortunately
makes it a less than compelling feature
film
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
number nine Blast from the Past Adam
Weber has lived his entire life in
confinement in a fallout shelter in
Pasadena California when the Weber
families rations of food and supplies
grow thin Adam's eccentric father Calvin
sends him on a dangerous restocking
Mission when Adam emerges from the Weber
family Subterranean refuge for the first
time he finds that rumors of a nuclear
apocalypse were totally false and meets
gorgeous Eve roostikov starring at
Brendan Frazier Alicia Silverstone
Christopher Walken and directed by Hugh
Wilson critics say cute idea but not
consistently funny
you almost got us killed I told you I've
never driven before we'll never drive
again you said it would be easy well I
was wrong
say is this your house yes I like it
what are you talking about now
what are you doing here
I forgot some of my stuff your stuff
yeah let me see that
oh you came back for your underwear
excuse me these are Ralph Laurens
how'd you get in
thanks
and who's this interesting looking
fellow this is Adam
I do fine Adam
how about yourself you uh
doing any good lately
go home Cliff wherever that might be
Sheena Gilroy's apartment you remember
her she's the model I went to Harvard
well I better be going
bye Adam
nice coat thank you Cliff it was very
nice to meet you that's a nice parking
job too
may I ask you a question he's a former
boyfriend we lived together for about
six months and yes I still have sort of
a thing for him that's what you wanted
to know isn't it no I was gonna ask you
why Cliff likes to wear another man's
Underpants
number eight School Ties when David
Green receives a football scholarship to
a prestigious Prep School in the 1950s
he feels pressure to hide the fact that
he is Jewish from his classmates and
teachers fearing that they may be
anti-semitic he quickly becomes a big
man on campus thanks to his football
skills but when his Jewish background is
discovered his worst fears are realized
and his friends turn on him with violent
threats and public ridicule starring
Brendan Fraser Matt Damon Chris
O'Donnell and directed by Robert Mandel
critics say led by an A-Plus cast the
road to School Ties is paved with good
intentions that are somewhat marred by
The Honorable yet heavy-handed message
against intolerance
uh excuse me um there's no salt on this
table I need salt for my fruit
if someone's not doing his menial job
you know it's so hard to find and help
these days
you can't move any faster please be care
to step outside I'll show you how fast
David come on it's not worth it David
it's not worth it all right
look my name is Richard Collins what's
yours Leesburg
David David I'll work your table you can
take mine all right listen man you need
this job as much as I do come on green
don't blow it all right
number seven Journey to the Center of
the Earth during an expedition to
Iceland Professor Trevor Anderson his
nephew Sean and their guide Hannah get
trapped in a cavern as they follow their
only Escape Route deeper and deeper
below the Earth's surface they pass
through strange places and encounter
incredible creatures including dinosaurs
but as volcanic activity around them
increases they realize they must find
their way out soon starring Brendan
Fraser Josh Hutcherson Anita bream and
directed by Eric brevig critics say
modern visuals and an old-fashioned
storyline make this family adventure
comedy a fast-paced kitschy ride
[Music]
duck
oops
large carnivorous plant
s
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get there
[Music]
that's one point for me right
let's keep on track right
number six The Mummy The Mummy is
arousing suspenseful and horrifying epic
about an expedition of treasure seeking
explorers in the Sahara desert in 1925.
stumbling upon an ancient tomb the
Hunter's unwittingly set loose a 3 000
year old Legacy of Terror which is
embodied in the vengeful Reincarnation
of an Egyptian priest who had been
sentenced to an eternity as one of the
Living Dead starring Brendan Fraser
Rachel Weiss John Hannah and directed by
Stephen Somers critics say it's
difficult to make a persuasive argument
for the mummy as any kind of meaningful
cinematic achievement but it's
undeniably fun to watch
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
can we just know
who the hell are these guys priests
emotive space all right then
number five still breathing Fletcher
mcbracken is San Antonio artist and
street performer who comes from a long
line of men who have had visions of
their future soulmate Roz Willoughby is
a cynical and sexy con artist who is out
for one thing money she and her
accomplice Elaine make a cozy Living
fleecing Rich Man in a fine art scheme
in La now when Fletcher thinks Roz is a
woman that he's seen in a vision he has
no idea she sees him as her next victim
starring Brendan Fraser Joanna going
Celeste Holm and directed by James F
Robinson Kevin Thomas from the LA Times
says there's a depth and caring to still
breathing that you don't find in the
usual major Studio fair so did I hear
you say something about a anything yes
those Starving Artists you hear about
really I'd love to see you work
in my car
oh yeah
I uh I'm an artist I
stack rocks really
yeah they're these um Cairns these
Monument kind of things
what you do is you get a bunch of rocks
and you stack them up
and you cram stuff in the cracks
and it's like a work of art
you wanna see
sure
first I'm gonna have to get my Elvis
rocks deck and swamp Mojo lined up here
well
I don't want to need your hand
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
number four crash writer director Paul
Haggis interweaves several connected
stories about race class family and
gender in LA in the aftermath of 9 11.
characters include a district attorney
and is casually prejudiced wife dating
police detectives Graham and Ria a
victimized Middle Eastern store owner
and a wealthy African-American couple
humiliated by a racist traffic cop
starring Brendan Fraser Sandra Bullock
Don Cheadle Jennifer Esposito and
directed by Paul Haggis critics say a
raw and unsettling morality piece on
Modern angst and urban disconnect crash
examines the dangers of bigotry and
xenophobia in the lives of
interconnected angelinos
I would like the locks changed again in
the morning and you know what you might
mention that we'd appreciate it if next
time they didn't send a gang member yes
yes well you mean that kid in there yes
the guy in there with the shaved head
the pants around his the prison tattoo
those are not presentations oh really
and he's not gonna go sell our key to
one of his gang banger friends the
moment he is out we've had a really
tough night I think it'd be best if you
just went upstairs and wait for them to
break in I just had a gun pointed in my
face you lower your voice and it was my
fault because I knew it was gonna happen
but if a white person sees two black men
walking towards her and she turns and
walks in the other direction she's a
racist right well I got scared and I
didn't say anything and 10 seconds later
I had a gun in my face now I am telling
you your Amigo in there is gonna sell
our key to one of his homies and this
time it'd be really [ __ ] great if you
acted like you actually gave
foreign
The Quiet American from the classic
novel by Graham green comes a murder
mystery centered on a love triangle set
against the French Indochina war in
Vietnam Circa 1952. that's the story of
a veteran English journalist a young
American and a beautiful Vietnamese
woman caught between them this is a
world where nothing is what it seems
suffused with opium Intrigue and
betrayal starring Michael Caine Brendan
Frazier Doty hyen and directed by Philip
noyce critics say thoughtful and
wonderfully acted The Quiet American
manages to capture the spirit of Green's
novel I'm not
ask you some questions
I'm from the American vacation let's try
to help people see
[Music]
the thing is I um
I got a cable from my wife
my boy has polio
and they don't know if he's gonna make
it
over here
I don't care if he's crippled I just
don't want him to die
[Music]
[Music]
number two no sudden move
set in 1954 Detroit no sudden move
centers on a group of small town
criminals who are hired to steal what
they think is a simple document when
their plan goes horribly wrong their
search for who hired them and for what
ultimate purpose weaves them through all
echelons of the race torn rapidly
changing City starring Don Cheadle
Benicio del Toro David Harbor Brendan
Fraser and directed by Stephen
Soderbergh critics say while it may not
be on par with his best crime Capers no
sudden move finds Soderberg on
entertainingly familiar ground and
making the most of an excellent cast
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
who are you Jones
you work for Frank
I've done work for Frank
this is not Frank okay because if he's
in I'm out what have I just told you
I can
do it look like it worked for eldrick
Watkins
[Music]
so what's the score
[Music]
we're sending a man that works in an
office to pick something up from that
office and bring it back to his home
you are part of a babysitting team
watching his family while he does it no
one gets hurt
three hours of work
for this
I'm offering you
two grand now and three on the other end
three hours
they said that your number was vibrant
is this something you think you can do
and finally number one Gods and Monsters
once a powerful Hollywood director best
known for Frankenstein and the Bride of
Frankenstein James whale is long since
retired and in increasingly poor health
his stalwart housekeeper Hannah quietly
disapproves of Wells faceless nameless
parade of young gay lovers but when the
director takes an interest in new
Gardener Clayton Boone a former Marine
and Korean War veteran it seems to be
for something more than its usual casual
Conquest starring Ian McKellen Brendan
Fraser Lynn Redgrave and directed by
Bill Condon critics say Gods and
Monsters is a spellbinding confusing
piece of semi-fiction featuring fine
performances McKellen leads away but
Redgrave and Frasier don't lag far
behind
me
like I told you I'm not that way get
through your [ __ ] head all right
foreign
[Music]
quickly
we've got this far
I'm losing my mind
every day I knew a piece of it comes and
soon coming on a bit left
the
Terrible
if you could be my second monster
come on please do it now take me
invisible
I am not
oh you're a monster
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of that
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]